this is the first in a two-part series
looking at the role of secondary markets
in energy efficiency financing please
keep an eye out for invitations for the
second webinar which we hold on March
31st this series has been developed in
partnership with the state and local
energy efficiency action or see action
network Lawrence Berkeley National Labs
and the AL Center for business and the
environments clean energy finance for
it's been designed around a report just
released by see action about accessing
secondary markets for energy efficiency
we've just posted a link to it in the
gotomeeting chat window it's a really
impressive report providing a really
good introduction to the topic but also
containing a lot of detail in case
studies and I'd really recommend
everywhere I'm listening today to check
it out today's presentation is being
brought to you by the team at the Yale
Center for Business and the environments
blueprint for efficiency which is in its
sixth year of providing public webinars
emphasizing the latest trends and
opportunities for energy efficiency each
presentation is recorded and available
through the Yale Center for business and
the environment website and the
blueprint proficiency iTunes you page a
link to download the slides from today's
presentation has also been posted in the
chat window we're delighted to welcome
today's presenters Emily modern
photo/hans hope I got that right ahem
chris creamer both of whom contributed
to the see action report emily is a
program manager at the in the
electricity markets and policy group at
Lawrence Berkeley National Labs and
chris is a senior consultant with energy
futures group with a focus on energy
efficiency financing before I turn it
over to the speakers i'd like to remind
our listeners that we welcome any
questions that you might have and will
direct them 12 speakers at the
conclusion of the talk will be allowing
plenty of time for questions so please
you know keep them coming you can type
these questions directly into the
gotomeeting chat window with that I'd
like to hand it over to Emily this is a
Johanna Zetterberg from the US
Department of Energy Michael I'm going
to be kicking us off today I am the
coordinator for the sea Action Network
and I want to
stay huge thank you to the Yale team for
partnering with us on bringing this
webinar to you today Before we jump into
today's topic I wanted to briefly go
over a little bit about reaction see
action provides state and local decision
makers with information on how to design
and implement energy efficiency policies
at programs successfully our information
is informed by state and local
experience to date and our materials
such as the reports that we're covering
today have been used by many state and
local government officials and energy
efficiency program administrators since
we began about five years ago as you can
see here on a slide we also have a
wealth of information in other areas
aside from financing solutions I invite
you to go to our website which is a
written in green and small print at the
bottom of this slide sweet action energy
gov for more information on those
materials next slide please Emily the
financing solutions working group
focuses on the key barrier of addressing
the high upfront costs of energy
efficiency improvement so as we go about
our work everything that we do is aimed
at addressing this barrier we currently
have four main focus areas the first is
improving data access looking across
data collection practices among energy
efficiency financing programs and
looking at considerations and best
practices in allowing program
administrators and policymakers to
access quality data on financing product
performance as well as other types of
data we also focus on ways to improve
program design we're also interested in
the question of whether new and novel
financing tools and capital sources are
needed in this space or whether
conventional ones can address the
barriers already so we're addressing
that question through our work and then
finally we're exploring the
natori treatment of energy efficiency
financing and what are the issues and
challenges that come up in that space
whether there are any recommendations
moving forward there for regulators and
their stakeholders next slide please
this is just a snapshot of who the group
is on the left hand side you see our
co-chairs we have Bruce aligned who is
the director of alternative energy
finance at City and brand Garcia who is
the president and CEO of the Connecticut
Green Bank I am a federal facilitator
along with my colleague writing from US
EPA and emily martin fighter hans will
hear from in just a moment leaves our
technical advisor team at Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab to the right you
can see all of our current members
representing a wide variety of expertise
and perspective next slide please here
is a snap
of the financing solutions working
groups website online please come here
to take a look at some of our other
resources for example we published
recently a report on on bail financing
we have others on credit enhancement and
a general financing program primer so
please please do visit the website
wouldn't get a chance and I'll now hand
it over to you Emily thank you very much
okay thank you johanna and want to echo
our thanks to the Yale team for setting
this up and to you all for attending and
taking time out of your day again i'm
emily martin potter hunts I'm with
Lawrence Berkeley Lab I'm going to take
us through about the first half of this
presentation and I'm going to pass it
over to our study primary author Chris
Kramer we have a lot to cover but we do
want to be interactive so we're going to
be taking questions throughout the
presentation so we'll pause occasionally
to take questions so please do type them
into the chat window and we're also do a
couple poles so we may go quickly but
we're excited to share this with you all
so you can see here the purpose of our
report is to discuss how secondary
markets have been used to date by energy
efficiency financing programs and also
how they could be used in the future and
the report was really inspired by some
of the early transactions of energy
efficiency loans that we saw in
secondary markets and then the hopes and
kind of aspirations for what secondary
markets could do for energy efficiency
financing that those transactions raised
and then we also cover sort of the other
side of the coin and try to succeed you
know are there any trade offs that using
secondary markets can introduce and then
overall we try to offer guidance and
suggestions for program administrators
who may be considering secondary market
strategies and I think we actually will
do our first poll at this point they
want to keep you all engaged so I'm
hoping that the Yale team can make that
happen because I'm not sure how to do it
but we have a pole for you all at this
point perhaps perhaps not
I'm oh shut up not only great thank you
so we're going to have Chris facilitate
this poll due to a quirk of the webinar
software i actually can't see it but
we'd love for you all to take an answer
to this take a look at this question and
give us a sense of what you think the
most important benefit of secondary
markets for energy efficiency is and my
glee can close it whenever you think the
folks have stopped answering
alright and Chris we use shy mixed with
the results thank you yes absolutely so
we had 23 actually good Oh as well it's
interesting what one answer in
particular is a little higher than the
others but 23% said lower borrowing
costs about twenty percent that
increased demand for energy efficiency
projects the high one is fifty five
percent so over half said increased
capital supply and then only two percent
said other so mostly one of the first
three options very cool great thank you
all for doing that and not surprisingly
we're going to talk about this later and
the answer is sort of all of the above
but that's really interesting to get
your take on what you all feel the
benefit of secondary market is so before
we dig in I'm going to do hopefully you
all are back to my slides and not the
poll results Chris just holler if we're
not thank you guys know what we're back
yep all right so just to level set on
some definitions that we're going to use
throughout this presentation first the
most basic what is the secondary market
so we define it as any market where a
product is resold after its original
sale and it could be something as simple
as me selling my car after I've owned it
for a while scalping tickets would count
as an example of a secondary market kind
of the most common one we think of is
the stock and bond market where there's
a you know an initial sale of a security
to investor but then it's traded
multiple times to secondary investors
after its original issuance and then in
the energy efficiency context the
secondary market is any financial market
where energy efficiency loans can be
sold to investors either as a single
loan or as a package of loans that's
divided into tradable instruments or
bonds and we'll talk through both of
those scenarios and then a brief word on
what we mean by energy efficiency
financing structures we do want to
remember that there are sort of two
general types of energy efficiency
financing structures or products that
are out there one are traditional
products things that already exists that
can be used for energy efficiency and
that would be your credit card your home
equity line
a mortgage existing products and we
don't focus on those as much in this
report but we do want to point out that
there's some interesting activity going
on in that traditional space and then
the flip side is our specialized
financing structures these are things
that probably talk about more things
like pace or on build products that are
tailored specifically to energy
efficiency and then we also have sort of
a gray category of loans that are
offered by an energy efficiency program
but are sort of more standard loan
product unsecured loans and that's the
focus of our presentation today so this
is to that this kind of speaks to the
your answers to the poll questions so
central premise of why we think
secondary markets are exciting for
energy efficiency finance and why we
think they're getting attention is laid
out here so one that secondary markets
can offer a greater supply of capital
and to that in the long run they may
offer a lower cost of capital which
would then translate through to lower
interest rates on energy efficiency
loans which would in theory lead to
higher demand so you can see that sort
of all of your answers to the poll
questions are kind of linked together on
greater capital supply I'll just say
that the thinking there is that
traditionally energy efficiency loans
are offered out of a limited pool of
dollars whether it's ratepayer funds or
federal funds whatever it is it's
typically a finite amount of dollars and
if if demand for energy efficiency won't
exceeds the amount of capital you have
available you get stuck in a pickle
where you can't be originating new loans
so the idea there is that secondary
markets could be a solution if your
demand outstrips your supply of capital
and on a little capital cost you see
here maybe lower in the long run I'll
just point out one there's many reasons
why secondary market capital can be
low-cost I'll point out one that we
speak about later which is liquidity and
what we mean by that is that that really
applies to bond structures but if you
have an instrument that you can trade
the investor is likely to require a
lower yield or a lower interest rate on
that money because if
confident that you know if I purchased
the bond and I didn't want it anymore I
wanted to get my money out I could just
sell it easily to Chris or to Johanna
and so I would feel less do if you're
less risky to me to own that asset and
we'll talk more about these throughout
the presentations so one dynamic that we
encountered in our research that we want
to call out up front is this is this
trade-off between short-term and
long-term objectives and what we found
is that while the secondary market for
energy efficiency is definitely in its
early stages we've only seen a handful
of transactions so far we also do see
some program administrators who seem
happy to be early adopters for lack of a
better word that's what this graph is
attempting to show you so the y-axis
here say would be level of current level
of demand or you know dollar amount of
loans that of energy efficiency loans
that have been taken out and so we do
see that there are some people in this
bottom left corner whose program maybe
it's still maturing maybe they're still
building demand but they want to take a
focus today on ensuring that the
products they're offering can be
attractive to secondary market investors
in the future once they need to access
that secondary market capital it makes
the other folks on the right-hand side
of the graph who prefer to wait to build
up demand and and loan volume before
they pursue a secondary market approach
that's just a dynamic that we saw up
there to be aware of and I think we've
another poll and we want to pause for
questions at this point before we go on
let's do maybe pause for questions first
and then move on to the pole so Michael
if there's any questions that have come
in we're happy to take a couple here and
if not then that's fine we can keep
going you were actually still awaiting
some questions from the audience so
let's go to the pole and then you know a
few questions come in after that we can
go to those otherwise we'll keep going
and just save a little bit more time at
the end sounds good you all should see
another poll coming up shortly and it's
related to you know imagine if you were
running an energy efficiency financing
program which does these approaches do
you think you would take would you be
focused on secondary markets now or
later or something else we're pretty
curious to understand how you always
feel about that choice
you
whenever you're ready whenever it seems
like responses are slowing Michael go
ahead and close it and then we'll have
Chris summarize the results for us great
so let's see so we had hi answers on the
first couple and a little lower on this
on the second couple so forty-three
percent said right away I'd be
interested in a one-stop shop option
forty-four percent said once I reached a
certain level of volume and then twelve
percent said I'd consider a capital a
supply alternative in the short term and
one for only one percent said I wouldn't
consider Sectary markets at all okay not
surprising since you probably wouldn't
join the webinar if you weren't
interested in secondary markets okay so
pretty even split between the kind of
consider them right away versus wait
until you've generated volume which not
surprising so thank you all for sharing
that with us and I think we're vente my
question oh sure sure but just come in
from mark and he asks can you talk about
the effect on underwriting standards
when leveraging secondary markets oh
absolutely i would i would rather defer
it Chris actually has a whole slide on
underwriting standards and other
criteria so if that's all right could we
take that a little bit later and I think
that as yes okay but Chris does have a
whole section on that's a good question
so for now I'm going to move into
discussing the secondary market
structures that we observed in doing
this research essentially how we're
energy efficiency loans sold and
packaged and what did that look like
before going into that I want to
emphasize that we focused on
transactions that are supported by the
repayments from the underlying energy
efficiency loans and so what I mean by
that is that we didn't look at examples
where for say a municipality issued a
general obligation bond that was just
based on their own credit worthiness and
then use those proceeds to issue energy
efficiency loans rather we looked at the
reverse scenario where the loans are
existing and then the the bond or the
folio sale is done based on those loan
assets and the reason we did that is
because that approach where you're
you're originating loans and then
accessing secondary market capital we
feel that that's more scalable because
as long as there's demand for loans you
can be creating secondary market
products and selling them on to
investors so we purposefully are
focusing on just those types of
transactions and you'll see here in this
figure that we saw basically two main
approaches one is a loan portfolio sale
and the other is bond sale and then
there's subcategories within bond sales
revenue bonds and then asset-backed
security nations and we'll go through
each okay on this slide I'm sure it's
pretty difficult to read that's fine we
don't want to discuss this in detail we
sort of want to put a plug here for our
second webinar where we will be focusing
more on some of these early transactions
of energy efficiency loans that we saw
there's ten overall eight that have
occurred in two that are forthcoming
I'll just make a couple points here on
this slide and just encourage you to
join the webinar on the 31st if you're
interested in hearing directly from some
of these programs so point i would make
here is that all these transactions are
pretty recent the oldest or the earliest
occurred in 2011 there are also all
fairly small volumes ranging from 15
million to 130 million at the largest
the underlying loans that the that the
secondary transactions are based on our
from most sectors there's residential
loans commercial loans public loans so
that's encouraging and then also each
transaction featured some kind of credit
enhancement chris is going to speak to
that point in a little more detail but
I'll just say that essentially that
means that investors seem to require a
little bit of risk mitigation for these
transactions to make them happen likely
because they're very new and are just
emerging so into
transaction structures the first one we
saw was called a loan portfolio sale
also called a direct loan sale and it's
a pretty straightforward route to
secondary market capital you can see it
kind of diagrammed here on the right you
start with program participants who are
taking energy efficiency loans and then
this blue box the originator who's
typically the program administrator then
just directly sell you know some or all
of those loans to another investor who
is a secondary market investor and what
doesn't happen is that the loans are
transformed in any way they're just
directly sold to this other investor
which makes this transit action more
simple but it also introduces a
challenge in that it can be difficult to
find an investor who wants to hold the
loan until maturity in their original
form these loans are tradable they're
not bond or packaged into securities so
that's the the downside but nonetheless
we do see this as a pretty
straightforward route to accessing
secondary market capital we saw at least
two examples of a portfolio sale that
successfully you know brought new
capital into the original program and
then the more common structure or the
structure that I think the vision of
secondary markets relies on are these
bond sales which is this next slide and
again there's two types of bond sales
that we saw revenue bonds and then asset
backed securities ation in the diagram
you'll see that the main difference
between the portfolio sale on the bond
sales is that you have this step where
the issuer creates a bond that's backed
by the loan revenues so the loans are
packaged and transformed into tradable
securities and then sold on to secondary
market investors so instead of buying
alone they're buying a bond security we
have a slide on revenues revenue bonds
vs asset backed securities ations I'll
just point out here that the difference
is that only certain types of entities
can issue revenue bonds typically
municipalities or of other public
agencies whereas asset backed securities
ations can be issued by any type of
organization they require a little more
a little more
complexity and that eutectic tend to
create new legal structures to hold the
loans and issue the loans and things
like that but they are accessible to all
kinds of issuers and then this light
green box on the bottom I'll just say
quickly that we did see that the
purchasers of these energy efficiency
backed bonds were from two major parts
of the bond market the private placement
market and then the public market and
when you think of you know the bond
market you're probably thinking of the
public market but there also exists a
private placement market which is a
little smaller probably at least an
order of magnitude if not more smaller
than the public bond market and the
purchasers in that market you know I
couldn't go and purchase a bond in the
private placement market it's only for a
certain type of investor so just note
that we may come back to that or we can
take some questions on that but we did
see that about half of the transactions
utilize the private placement market
instead of the public market so a last
word on transaction structures before I
hand it over to Chris who is going to
change gears and take us to the second
half of the report just comparing
quickly revenue bonds versus
asset-backed securities Asians so these
are the two primary bond approaches that
we saw revenue bonds as I mentioned are
only available to certain types of
entities although it is does seem fairly
easy to create a partnership with a
public sector entity if you need to
revenue bonds are relatively simple
simple and they may have lower
transaction costs and asset-backed
securities ations there are fewer fewer
parties involved because you don't need
to create these special legal entities
or special purpose vehicles to hold the
loans and rating agency fees may also be
lower because the rating methodologies
for a revenue bond a municipal revenue
bond are a little more straightforward
than for an asset backed securities
ation however asset backed securities
ations you could argue provide a path to
a larger total pool of capital asset
backed securities ations tend to be
created in tranches which essentially is
just kind of a different flavor
a bond that may be attractive to a
certain kind of investor so that by
creating those trenches you might
attract the larger total pool of
investors to your bond sale and the
asset backed securities market is a
little bit larger than the municipal
revenue bond market so both of these
markets are very large and certainly are
sufficient to meet demand for energy
efficiency loans that were receiving
today but just want to point that out
that there are these kind of two bond
markets that are out there and two
approaches that we saw so we can um
pause for questions now and then we will
pass this over to Chris Chris do you
want me to make you the presenter or do
I me to advance the slides for you oh
that's fine you can make me to the
presenter I will work on that while we
take any questions that have come in
great thanks Emily we do have a few
questions coming right now so the first
one from Joe is are there any instances
you know of where investor owned
utilities have directly engaged in
secondary market transaction hmm not
that I am aware of you know oftentimes
the utility is involved in some fashion
in these in these energy efficiency
programs but typically the issuer has
been a public entity or a municipality
or it's been a private a private entity
like a private energy efficiency loan
finance here actually a family i'll just
add a little bit too bad two two two
quick points 1 if you really
specifically focus on iou's in other
words investor owned utilities as
opposed to sort of more broad the
broader category of you know program
administrators we don't have examples in
this paper of that I you know I'm not
sure that there been any but there are
some examples of other kind of analogous
program administrators you know like
NYSERDA and the Delaware seu that are
you know program administrators who have
gone through these types of transactions
the other thing which I won't get into a
lot of detail but a little bit has been
that enough publicly at this point that
I think I can just go ahead and save it
there is some exploration of you know
possible secondary market activity among
utilities in catechism us as well say on
that at this point in some of that's in
process but but that's being
investigated and and what I just said is
is a look at this point alright great so
we um I guess one more question maybe
now before we we start with you Chris
and that comes from Tom who asks are
there sample energy efficiency contracts
available for us to review between
program participants and the program
administrator to show what cash flow is
guaranteed so what cash flow is
guaranteed between the program I think
the question is probably around maybe
you know how in mortgage contracts you
can go and look the standard mortgage
agreement is anything like that for
energy efficiency there maybe not that
I've seen that are easily publicly
available but it's possible that these
program administrators could share
especially if you're considering a
program I imagine they would be open to
sharing some of their loan agreements
with you or they may be publicly
available if you work you know if you do
do your due diligence and wind your way
down do you know of any Chris that are
like a standard version of an energy
efficiency loan agreement maybe I'm just
getting a little hung up on sort of the
relationship if it's between the IC
between the program administrator and
the customer yeah I'm sure there are
some examples probably out there I'm
trying to you know of those types of
agreements that we could you know dig up
and share in terms of sort of its impact
on secondary markets I think that's what
I'm trying to think through in terms of
the answer but you know we do talk a
little bit and it's useless from now
about you know what in fact actually
right here sort of what investors are
expecting and one of the things they
will look at is
you know what's the risk on the
underlying cash flows and so that that
might be you know you know I'm seeing
the actual agreements might be something
that you know would be of interest to
understand you know the likelihood that
the cash flows are repaid so you know it
may come into play in that sense so I
think I'll leave it there for now okay
should we go ahead can you all see my my
slides at this point yep we can see them
great great okay so as I just mentioned
we'll talk a little bit about investor
for investor perspectives so one of the
things if you you know have a need for
accessing capital through the secondary
markets that's fundamental is to work
with the investor community to address
any concerns about the underlying risks
of the loans that are either being sold
directly or are backing the bond
transaction there are essentially two
ways that we identify in the report that
those concerns can be addressed one is
to provide sufficient information about
the underlying loans or other financing
arrangements that the investor feels
comfortable about you know that they
really understand what the risk is and
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
always a low risk it might just mean
that they you know are feel familiar
enough with with the transactions to
address that risk if the risk is a
little higher there might be a higher
premium but at least making giving them
enough history so that they feel
comfortable and I think in a lot of
cases you know the perception among
program initiated beers is that the risk
may be lower or than is sometimes
perceived in the investment community in
part due to lack of familiarity so one
of the goals of of some program
administrators in thinking about
secondary markets is how can we bridge
that gap or narrow that gap between
perceived and actual risk and one of the
ways to do that is to build up a
consistent performance history that you
can bring to the investor community to
provide them as much information as
possible about your transactions that
said there are certainly plenty of
programs
there that are relatively new they may
not have a you know as much of a
performance history or the data that
they've collected may not be in the form
that investors are looking for or there
may be certain things about the you know
transaction structures that make
investors at least for now feel less
comfortable and so there are certainly
other ways to work with the investor
community as well to structure the
transaction to mitigate risk and of
course one of the things that Emily
mentioned earlier that can be a major
piece of that is is offering various
types of credit enhancements and there's
a slide later that that talks about some
of those types of enhancements in fact
here it is so we talked a little bit
about first of all you providing
information and building up a
performance history one of the things
I'll say about this in addition is that
even for programs that may not have a
whole lot of loan volume of initially or
maybe that may not be in a place where
they currently need capital from the
secondary markets some programs still
even early on may decide to structure
their their loans and their transactions
in a way that they think investors will
be comfortable with in the future when
that need becomes more salient to them
in fact one of the rationales for
joining some of the more kind of what we
call it cookie cutters wrong word but
kind of standardized structures that are
out there that we pursued that we
explore in the paper is precisely that
that the transaction history that you'll
build by participating in one of those
structures is specifically intended and
designed to be built up in a way that
makes investors feel comfortable that
said again if if need be you can
certainly also structure in various
types of credit enhancement I won't go
through this whole list but it's it is
explored and and defined in the report
but just note that there are many
different types of credit enhancement
that can make investors feel more
comfortable everything from selling
loans if it does count
to providing guarantees or loan loss
reserves in some cases the program
administrator might for example provide
subordinate capital which would
potentially take a first or take a loss
and if it returns aren't quite what they
expect and that risk would go first to
thee to the program before it goes to
the investors or the investors might not
provide the full amount of the sort of
net present value of the expected cash
flows they would actually provide a
little less and and that's basically you
know essentially selling selling the
loans at a discount it should just be
noted that you know all of these things
are not without cost so accessing
secondary markets there are a number of
reasons why there can be costs
associated with it a credit enhancements
is definitely a big one of those I think
at this point in particular given that
were sort of an early stages in the
market the amount of credit enhancement
that may be needed can be somewhat
significant that's not always true it
depends a little bit on what your
transaction structure is so for example
we do explore some haste transactions
where the security on the loans is
looking fairly high to begin with the
amount of additional credit enhancement
maybe less but in a lot of cases we did
see that the amount of credit
enhancement needed was either
significant to begin with or may have
actually gone up when a sale was made so
on that note there are also some program
design considerations to take into
account when you are thinking about you
know whether to build in secondary
markets as a consideration into an
energy efficiency financing program this
kind of goes back to Emily's slide on
supply focused and demand focused
perspective one of the things to think a
little bit about is you know how do I
best build demand for energy efficiency
and use financing as a tool to do that
am I better off you know setting rates
and terms in ways that are most flexible
most attractive and you know will
generate the highest amount of
participation or do I need to think a
little bit more long-term and say well
by the time I get to a point where
may need to access additional capital
from the investor community I all have
wanted to set things up from the
beginning in ways that make that
community feel comfortable so that I can
then access more capital a future and
those are just things that need to be me
be considered there's sometimes ways of
bridging that gap and doing both but
these are program design considerations
that are worth taking into account so it
certainly interest rates you know there
are a lot of energy efficiency programs
that offer fairly low or even zero
percent interest there are ones that
offer longer terms we had an example of
a lender who offered 20 year terms
initially and then cut that back in part
because of thinking about you know how
to make the loans most saleable and
underwriting criteria this goes back to
the the question that was posed
initially which was you know how do
secondary markets affect underwriting
criteria so I don't think that there's a
you know one single answer to that
question but I think as a general
principle you know investors may have a
different perspective than energy
efficiency program administrators in
terms of how to set underwriting
criteria so you know for example if on
the residential side you know where you
set your minimum fico score or where you
set your debt to income ratio how much
debt you think you know borrowers should
be able to take on for example that
might be different from a policy
perspective and in terms of providing
access to capital to sort of the
broadest you know none still prudent but
kind of a broader range of potential
customers then investors might be come
through with in some cases so that's
another another sort of consideration to
take in mind there are some programs
nyserda was one that we looked at that
actually established two tiers of
underwriting specifically for to address
this concern one of the you know Tier
one was essentially the tier that was
meant to be saleable in tier 2 was the
one that was meant to be more flexible
so there are things like that that you
can potentially explore in program
design but they are also you know
obviously additional kind of
administrative costs that come along
with that and it's also just hard to
know from the beginning well where do I
draw the line you know what will invest
really become purvis and and how do I
decide and you know maybe I'll have
accesses and cut enhancement later that
would actually allow me to sell more
current more loans than I thought so
those things are kind of hard to be
guessed from the beginning but there are
possibly ways to bridge the gap another
program design consideration is you know
what type of security will be attached
to your loan so i mentioned taste for
example there you know maybe some
advantages i'm given the you know with
this isn't a paste webinar but i'm sure
you guys are a lot of you at least
pretty familiar with the additional
security that tastes can provide and you
know if investors are in a pretty secure
position then maybe they'll be somewhat
more comfortable with the transaction
and require less less credit enhancement
to get them over the line there's also
some discussion of tune of on bill loans
and whether shut off could you know
provide that type of security but i
think that's an outstanding question at
this point so bottom line you know
program administrators should be aware
of all these trade-offs when they think
about you know setting up an energy
efficiency a financing program or you
know what changes they may want to make
to it there's no sort of right answer
here it's just about you know how do I
build demand at the same time you know
making my program I'm attractive enough
that if I need secondary market capital
in the future I'll be able to get it one
other factor to keep in mind as you're
thinking about all of those
considerations is that there are some
other ways you know out there and Emily
mentioned a few of these earlier to get
capital for your program and and really
one of the things you want to think
about is well how much capital at what
point will I need to access a additional
capital beyond what I have right now so
Emily mentioned for example that in many
cases energy efficiency financing
programs start by using either public or
ratepayer capital just to make direct
loans you know there are obviously a
bunch of programs that are partnering
with private capital providers as well
whether the local lenders or or other
sources but just at the most basic level
you know if you have access to public or
repair funds and you're just trying to
build demand those are certainly
low-cost funds that can you know allow
you to be pretty flexible in how you set
up your program but of course you know
over time as demand does build you may
be somewhat limited in the amount that
you can can provide in fact a couple of
programs that we looked at specifically
started out with that type of capital
and the reason that needed to access the
secondary market with was precisely
because they basically ran out of the
amount of money that they could access
with that type of source another way to
do it is just to its develop any
obligation bond I believe Emily mention
that one as well you know states and
municipalities and some other sort of
quasi public entities may have the
ability to sell a bond that they can
then use the proceeds to fund you know
say revolving loan fund or that type of
thing but again there are often are
limits on how much of that type of
activity or these considerations about
how much of that type of activity you
know those those types of entities can
take on and so you know at some point
they may need to look beyond that as a
source there are some interesting
example too of selling rapier back bond
so for example gatien bond but instead
of the credit of the municipal entity
backing the bond it might be just sort
of ratepayers more generally so Hawaii
with their gems model which I can't even
remember right now with i stands for but
as an example of this and again
relatively low cost capital but
eventually maybe maybe someone limited
and then lender networks so
massachusetts heat loan is an example of
this you know massachusetts has got
something like 50 to 60 local lenders
that fund their heat loan program and
you know they're able to get up to in
the range now of around 100 million
dollars a year so you know there really
is a lot of capital that you can
potentially access with that type of
network and they're there you know
they're still relatively low cost they
may not be as low cost as they repair
funds but they're lending at around five
percent which is then bought down to
zero over a period of seven maximum term
of seven years so you can really get a
lot of you know capital depending on
where
you are with your program using those
local lender networks so yo again in the
short run these alternatives may you
know come with lower costs but in the
long run basically the bottom line here
is capital may be constrained I think we
were we were going to original take a
question after 18 and I forgot about
that so Michaels there are other
questions I'm happy to take them after
this slide and said yeah we actually
have a question directly on the slide
you just presented then we have a few
sort of going back maybe we posed that
first question and then maybe one other
and then we keep going Lisa asks why do
you say that general obligation bonds
are not tied to energy efficiency loan
revenues take a state energy line
program funded with general obligation
loans borrowers repay these were these
funds over time right right I think the
yeah I I think you know what least in
some examples what will happen is you
know you sell the bond and the funds
really are repaid through some other
type of tax or you know other levy
that's really the primary source for
repaying that general obligation bond
and the loan itself is I'm sorry the
bond itself is really backed by the
credit of the issuing entity in that
case so they're really kind of two
distinctions here yes you can certainly
put those funds into a revolving loan
fund but often the repayment then we'll
just be recycled within that revolving
loan fund and lent out again so I think
the two sort of key distinctions are you
know where is the real source of
repayment for that bond coming from and
also you know kind of what is the
underlying I guess there's a sort of a
later point but what's the underlying
backing for that bond so as Emily
mentioned earlier one of the real
thoughts about scaling up energy
efficiency financing programs using
secondary market capital is that those
transactions tend to be back really
directly with the not with the credit of
the issuing entity which can limit the
amount that they can do but really just
directly with the underlying loans and
that you know the more of that type of
activity you can do the sort of larger
your program can get emily in the King
way about great Emily anything to add to
that so I think that's well said maybe
the maybe the important word is only
backed by the revenues from energy
efficiency loans which is the structures
that we're focusing on here these
revenue bonds and asset-backed
securities ations where they don't have
the fall back of the general faithful
Faith and Credit of a municipality or a
state backing them and the investors
look at those energy efficiency loans
Len as the only asset or collateral that
they will be repaid from vs well yes
maybe I'll get rid maybe these loans
will perform maybe they won't but even
if they don't I'll still have the state
you know I know the state will make good
on its GL bonds great great maybe I'll
go on actually if you can hold the
second question just let me make sure we
get through the rest of the slides and
leave time without that works for them
and okay great they're only actually a
couple more slides here but we did want
to point out then this goes to the
report as well that we had created a
sort of decision tool Emily worked hard
on this and I did a great job and put
together a decision tool that helps walk
you through sort of if you're in the
stage of program design how should you
think about integrating secondary
markets or how and whether I guess in a
great secondary markets into your
program design so I won't walk through
the whole thing but at a general level
you know the first question is basically
what's your level of demand now and what
is it likely to be in the future for
energy efficiency financing essentially
how much capital do you think you'll
really need and then it goes down into
questions around what capital supply
options are available to you secondary
markets and some of the other
alternatives that we talked about and
then assuming that those options are all
available it then it then moves on to
okay well what are the you know pros and
cons
trade-offs of those various options and
what are some of the considerations to
think about the amount of capital supply
the cost in the long run versus some of
the program design and trade-offs for
example and some of the shorter term and
costs like credit enhancement that we've
reviewed so hopefully that tool will be
helpful to folks in thinking about how
to incorporate all of this into their
program designs so then just another
couple more two more summary slides this
is all stuff that I think we've mostly
reviewed but in the long run secondary
markets offer essentially a virtually
limitless you know low-cost capital
source but right now we're still really
at the early stages of all this stuff so
you know we reviewed a transactions it
doesn't capture everything there are
other ones out there in the market but
but it actually captures a pretty good
cross-section and of what's been done so
far you know at around four hundred
million dollars that you know often
you'll hear folks say that really
anything from 25 to 50 to 100 million is
kind of almost like a minimum level for
what you might expect in the secondary
market transaction and you can see in
terms of where we are right now that
we're still you know relatively lower
levels but certainly certainly the
market is developing you know some
program administrators may choose to
focus on secondary market strategies
right now and build up a transaction
history so that they can get the capital
when they need it whereas others may
choose to make program design choices
that will help them build demand and
meet other policy objectives such as you
know open access to capital and then we
reviewed two main sources of too many
types of secondary markets loan
portfolio sales second or market
transactions including loan portfolio
sales and bond sales within that you
know we looked at municipal revenue
bonds and asset-backed securities ations
and you know you know we made the point
that all secondary market transactions
you know do have to build in risk
mitigation strategies whether that's
providing information or right now
providing credit enhancement and other
things that may you know make carry cost
with them so just something to think
about and finally balancing sort of
long-term and short-term objectives
you know program administrators should
think about you know what are the
considerations that they'll have to take
into account if they want to build
secretary markets into their program
design interest rates security
mechanisms and underwriting criteria
first is the ability to meet long-term
capital needs and access low-cost
capital over time think about you know
as you're thinking about all this what's
your level of demand likely to be and
what are your options and constraints
when you think about which which of
those on which of those avenues to
pursue great so I think that's it and
with that we can take any more questions
got about the five input great thanks so
much guys okay so I've got one well I've
had a couple of people ask questions
that are related to the same topic which
is about the unique challenges that
energy efficiency projects pose when it
comes to secondary markets you know the
unique quality assurance with issues mmv
protocols and how those are actually
carried out in these in these
transactions those only if either of you
could speak a little bit about about
that
sure so M&V protocols and I'm sorry what
was the first piece of that I was just
QA quality assurance and how Bob you
know typically about how M&V protocols
would fit into that process right right
I'll try to answer that from sort of a
broader perspective which is to say that
you know I think one of the key themes
that we do look at in the paper is the
idea of standardization and energy
efficiency as an asset class and I think
QA and mmv protocols sort of play into
that in the sense that you know one of
the long-term potential objectives of
building secondary markets into energy
efficiency programs is the idea that you
know over time it may be possible to
demonstrate a link between project
performance and loan performance that is
to say you know the better your energy
efficiency project performs in terms of
throwing off those underlying cash flows
the more likely it is that you'll you
you know you as a customer will be to
repay your loan or the more likely it is
that the investor will see the return to
say inst expect so I think things like
QA and M&V protocols can make investors
eventually over time as they get more
familiar with the market become more
comfortable that that that you know that
that link exists is real and you know
may over time such as their costs I
think I keep saying overtime and kind of
copy outing that because I think that's
what right now will work in progress and
there are a lot of questions around that
that kind of remain to be answered but
that's that's the general principle
Emily Emily I would be I would just say
that that currently probably the
majority of investors aren't aren't
haven't seen enough data or aren't
familiar enough with energy efficiency
loans to follow that story line of
reduced risk due to the fact that energy
efficiency loans generate savings I
think that it is definitely an overtime
issue okay great
Oh Chris as you predicted there is some
interest around paste programs amongst
our listeners and one of the questions
was why we haven't seen much action on
secondary markets regarding paste
programs great a good question although
i will say that actually a couple of the
transactions that we looked at our pace
transactions so we didn't focus that
much directly on pace in this webinar i
will say Emily mentioned the webinar on
the 31st and I don't think that we've
quite finalized all that but I believe
we will be highlighting a commercial
pace transaction in that webinar so stay
tuned hmm and you know I mean I think I
think you know the fundamentally it's
our underlying that is that number one
there have been a few number two you
know there's a relatively limited number
of underlying transactions on the
residential side you know we don't need
to get into all of it but obviously
there have been some regulatory issues
around residential pace that have
limited the number of you know
jurisdictions that have moved forward on
it but there are some and the hero
transactions that we mentioned are
structured around a residential taste
structure and they're described in the
report and then on the commercial side
you know they're all there are not as
many regulatory issues but they're also
you know sort of a limited number of
programs that I think I've done enough
volume to reach the point where they
have mute attacks the secondary markets
Connecticut is certainly one and we do
talk about that and the report and I
believe that we'll be talking about that
on the 31st and Toledo is also another
one on the commercial side where they
structured a you know the program around
pace and have actually access to the
secondary market there so it's you know
it's moving along well do
anything to add family nope let's try to
fit another question good ok great ok
now another couple of questions from
Brian and Timothy around efforts at the
federal level so a lot of your
presentation is focused on state or
municipal level efforts do you see any
efforts or potential for any efforts at
the federal level i'ma leave you want to
take that one or gosh other than to say
you know nothing imminent I as far as
potential for at the federal level I
haven't thought through that in too much
detail I think you're right that you
know at this juncture it is pretty kind
of program administrator by program
administrator which is part of the
challenge Chris mentioned
standardization as something that could
help this market to evolve I suppose you
know much as we saw in the mortgage
market of federal government org infidel
regulators could take a hand in
standardization but I think that's a
ways off I think program administrators
are still figuring out what works for
them and their target markets so I think
I wouldn't see that in the to near
future what do you think Chris yeah I
think I mean it's basically right i mean
i do i think that you know a few of the
you know agencies out there like you
know fannie mae for example was engaged
highly engaged in the residential energy
load side of things for a while and
there is some data there that's you know
been useful to folks who are exploring
the potential secretary market
transactions FHA is another agency and
pud you know that where there might be
some potential there and the other thing
is you know it's not federal but you
know there are couples transtech
transaction structure as we explore like
wheel and kilowatt that are open to
multiple states so it again it's not not
federal per se but it does cross
multiple jurisdictions great
okay well I think I think that's all the
time we have so with that I'd like to
thank Johanna Emily and Chris for what's
been a really stimulating and I think
you know really interesting presentation
I'd like to remind all of you is that we
have a second webinar in this series
that will be on march 31st that will be
focused really on these case studies so
looking in detail the number of examples
of secondary market transactions across
the residential the sea and I and the
institutional sectors I'd like to remind
everyone that the report that we've been
referencing throughout this presentation
is available the link to it is in the in
the GoToWebinar window a window and that
this talk today will be made online I
will be made available online through
the Yale Center for business and the
environment website so where this is
Michael pocket from the Yale Center for
business in the environment Thanks so
long the new haven connecticut